ladies and gentlemen welcome to another
episode of coffeezilla today
we're at a whole another level of scam
we're at flying lambo
levels of scam of course let's go to the
board
bitclout yes if the name doesn't already
give it
away to you they're trying to mimic
bitcoins
notoriety popularity they say they're
the bitcoin of like
profiles of social media have you heard
this before buzz buzz buzz buzzword i'm
i'm just like satoshi guys i swear
i'm just like satoshi but they got big
founders they got
chamath they got sequoia capital they
got a lot of big boys
what are they seeing that i'm not [ __ ]
big clout it's hot on the market right
now why do i think it's scam why all
these guys are cashing in
let's find out today shall we let's
examine
let's investigate this 200 million
dollar
scam something i allege is a scam by the
way founder
he's anonymous yeah just let's start
there but okay that's fine right you say
what
what when has a anonymous founder ever
been a scam
fair enough let's talk about it we'll
start with the white paper
bitcloud is a new social network which
lets you speculate on people and post
with real money
and it's built from the ground up as its
own custom blockchain boys
so here's how it works you buy a coin
called bitclout which you use internally
to the website
to purchase like creators and speculate
on creators there's only one
tiny problem how do you buy big clout
with bitcoin
now can you sell big clout
back for bitcoin does it work the other
way well
the answer to that question is a
resounding no
uh the money goes to the anonymous
founder it seems or somebody we don't
know who
it just goes to an address an address
which is now received
uh let's check that real quick let me
see if my numbers are right oh
that's right 200 million dollars boys
200 million dollars
yes of usd that uh you're not going to
get back
look you bought in this stupid platform
you're not going to get it back so
what do you get for buying bitcloud well
the only thing you can really do with it
is by these creator coins and
everybody has a coin guys you can buy
your favorite person's coin
people like this now there's only one
small problem
the exciting people who are on this list
that they're selling
they've tokenized everybody and they're
selling them as creator coins
have those people bought into the
platform that would be a resounding
no so it turns out they're just stealing
people's identity
and selling it as crypto is it a scam
yet
can we say that oh no no no totally not
a scam guys this is real this is a real
project
not a quick cash grab look who it's
backed by guys it's backed
it's backed by chamath it's backed by
sequoia capital
there could be no ulterior motives here
see they actually did a pre-sale for
founders and investors so
investors might make some money but uh
you well you'll probably lose out well
because literally you can't what are you
gonna do with the big clout
how are you gonna sell it you can't how
do you get the big cloud out of the
platform
what sell it for more big clout hey i'll
sell you some
mr beast if you sell me some leon lush
tokens dude
no bro what is this what is this new
economy
everything has to be tokenized no it
doesn't guys i understand that
everyone's excited about bitcoin
everyone thinks it's gonna save the
universe all of a sudden the world's not
gonna end anymore because we've
decentralized it and it's on everybody's
comp you can download the earth on
everyone's computer now
sorry to say it's not gonna work that
way but anyways back to the part where
they're using people's identity without
their permission
so here they have elon musk right and
people have been buying elon musk's
profile
they pitch it as we're saving his
profile for but in reality all they've
done is they've copied his profile and
let people pay money
inside of his thing and given him a
market cap so allegedly
his market cap is 38 million dollars
which is probably inflated right it's
probably inflated
but they've made money off elon musk and
elon musk has seen none of that
does everybody understand why that's
wrong and they're gonna get
sued for it and it looks like that's
actually coming down the pipe we'll talk
about that in a second
uh but this profile is reserved if elon
musk has not joined bitcloud yet
meaning elon musk could hate big clout
and think it's a scam but they're
profiting off of him now do you guys
what's gonna happen if elon musk goes
hey give the people their money back are
they gonna get their money back
probably not because did i mention that
the founder is anonymous
oops the founders diamond hands
now some people have pointed to this guy
uh being this guy
nader nader theory because yeah they
sent him a
cease and desist letter actually for
using you know
an identity without that person's
consent but to just tell you guys how
insane this stuff is just think about it
this way let's say i launch a crypto
coin i say hey guys
come to i steal your ip.com
and buy some tokens right and it's like
theft coin
dot co or something like whatever and
all of a sudden the first thing you can
buy with it is a mario token or a luigi
token
nintendo has not given me the rights to
use that i'm profiting off of them
and if nintendo comes knocking on my
door hey
i just say well hey you can claim it you
can claim it here's the thing with
bitclout
here's the little growth hack that
they're trying to use
which is that people can claim their
bitclout
their big club profiles and get a
percentage
of that token now the key word is
percentage though
because big cloud's taking the majority
the lion's share
bit cloud has already made the money on
the bitcoin transferred into bit clout
so what are you actually getting are you
getting worthless tokens where's the
actual value
the actual value is in this wallet which
is allegedly where all the money from
this thing has been going to
uh to transfer stuff into bitcloud 209
million usd made from theft
scams guys it's so
easy these days all you need is a
pseudo-anonymous account create just
some
sketchy white paper with a bunch of
buzzwords do some pump of mentals get
some
founders on board by saying hey uh
you're a big in crypto come to my thing
i'll give you some easy cash
and then promote it to all your
followers we'll steal people's identity
and get make it seem like our platform's
bigger than it is and we rake in a cool
200 million dollars but probably the
stupidest thing of all
is this idea like bitcoin big cloud is a
fully open source project and there's no
company behind it
it's just coins and code have you ever
heard this before
hey this thing got created but no one's
behind it
who could be behind it we don't know
there's investors but they must not be
behind it
because apparently it's just coins and
code hmm
where's all that money go then that's
turning the bit clout
into bitcoin is that going to anybody if
so
it's owned by that person who's getting
all the rewards yo if you get scammed by
this
don't say i didn't warn you because this
is so shameless and shady how they're
getting people to buy in by basically
pre-selling your
your stuff without your consent and
going hey come in and get a cut
they call it the founders rewards
actually uh where you can like set your
little fee
and the founder the founder reward
percentage all this kind of stuff
it's so stupid this stuff makes me so
mad
when i watch a project pretend to be
like altruistic pretend to be like
hey guys we're just an open source cool
project and it's like one guy getting
super rich
wow where's the money going that's my
question not the big
clout coins where's the bitcoin going
which is being used to buy this
i don't like it it is a giant scam you
can translate to
this to any other world imagine
pre-selling or tokenizing
any kind of ip without consent be like
hey
i'm selling this guy's identity it'd be
like selling merchandise
uh for any movie and then being like
yeah you know they didn't
officially authorize it but i'm sure
they'll be cool with it
now in addition to them taking really
popular profiles and pre-loading them on
the platform another
problem and another form of identity
theft
is where they literally someone else
takes your profile
and uploads it this happened to uh my
buddy here roberto blake you guys may
know him from his youtube channel
this happened to you right like somebody
just made a it's it says
official account rest equal scam
creative entrepreneur coach 500k
youtube podcaster keynote speaker and
there's three thousand dollars that's
been spent on this
coin that's you yeah it means that i
mean they literally are scamming
like my fans and people who would want
to support me and like i don't even have
a big cloud account
i only found out about this because one
of my fans told me about it
they want to capitalize on the creator
space without fully understanding it
this relationship between investors and
creators
is gonna go well initially because i
don't think they respect the space
i don't think they understand it and i
don't think they respect the
relationship creators have with their
fans
it's these big names that they want to
take advantage of and all the
recognition and traffic so they just
want to leverage
uh these people for their audience and
if it goes sideways
they're going to leave people with a
reputation-based business hold in the
bag
it's not cool it does look like legal
action is being taken as i mentioned
before
already seasoned assist letters are
going out and yeah
i only see more of this happening but by
then it seems like
the money will be probably gone i fully
expect some kind of prosecution to go
down with this
i think what they're doing is absolutely
deplorable and i think it just makes the
crypto space worse
because it just plays into this
pre-existing kind of fear of scams and
crypto because there's so many people
getting stupid rich by making these
short-sighted
scam coins scam offering scam platforms
it's like what are we doing here anyways
i don't like it i don't like this
company i don't like anything they stand
for
that's it for now thanks for watching
i'll see you in the next one
i know what you need this ain't what it
seems nothing but a trick trying to sell
me on a dream but
that was where you lost me wake up and
smell the coffee